[Music]
okay hi everyone I'm Grandmaster Brian
Smith the subject of today's class is
going to be romantic chest which was
defined as well for this class is from
the dawn of time until the Year 1880
according to my understanding so I've
chosen a game which is played by all the
black player was Joseph Blackburn very
one of the top players of this time his
opponent was named Gustav Norman I'd
never heard of I mean I think I've heard
of this player but he he's not someone
who really went in history is very well
remembered but apparently he was a
strong player because when I when I
looked for this game there on the
database their actual tournament games
between these two players know a man had
won a couple of games I think it was two
wins and 1-1 draw but this was
apparently a an often off hand game
where according to what I read it
there's notation here I mean there was
notes by by Blackburn throughout this
this game which didn't really deal so
much with the game and Moore was kind of
very sparse notes that he'd made in him
in I think for a collection of his own
games but was not really so much about
the actual game and just little
anecdotes about but any case it was
apparently a it was an offhand game
where Norman challenged Blackburn for
one sovereign so so of course it started
with the Kings gambit this was by the
way this was played in 1860 so and I'm
not sure where it doesn't didn't say I'm
sure I could find the source but I know
so of course it started with the Kings
gambit
so the favorite opening of Romantic era
and this is it's also an opening I used
to play the Kings gambit a lot in
tournaments it was my only opening in
c-45 for
quite awhile until something like until
I until I was almost an I am I guess but
it really it's it's hard to play that
all the time okay so black took the pawn
Knight f3 g5 and this was one of the
biggest problems with the Kings yeah but
just accepting it and protecting with g5
so now Bishop c4 this is this is a this
is a Koziol game but I believe it's
called F if black plays g4 here no one
plays it really any more at this this
nowadays or for the last century or so
everyone has played h4 in this position
and after g4 95 and it's it's kind of
dubious for white to you how to admit
but it's it's it's a fun game though but
the idea is to poke holes in the King
sight because one of the problems is
this black has created this pawn chain
g5 and f4 and this is going to keep
White's Bishop from c1 from ever getting
into we have to break up this pawn chain
but in this case white develops a little
bit first so Bishop c4 now after g4 what
do you think White's gonna play here
oh and kind of get some idea about the
level with players that are what people
that are watching what do you think in
the front oh well night yeah Knight g5
the Queen would take yeah 95 but
probably a Queen h4 check and this is
because kind of dubious for white anyway
normally what what is played here yeah
do you know yeah this is an old gambit
and it's actually pretty dangerous for
black but I think it's I don't know if
it's no one plays it anymore it's not
very sound but and then and then to play
down a piece but with black has problems
on the F file
and white as the center and it's blacks
to development is going to going to be a
little bit a little bit difficult so but
that's not what black chosen this game
he decided to play Bishop g7 just not
taking the piece and developing he
develops a bishop and he's going to
strengthen his pawn chain
okay so white white now play d4 black
played d6 and White Castle and black
played aged six so blacks up upon and
these see if this works
okay we're yeah so these pawns are are
keeping this Bishop on c1 from from
being part of the game and also keeping
the F file close so if the things just
go normally black is going to develop 97
probably 96 maybe Castle there's other
things black can do try to hit back with
d5 or something some cases can play
Bishop e6 when when black hasn't played
96 or other ways to prepare castling
queenside as well but basically white
needs to get something going so he
played g3 here so it looks a little bit
crazy to open up the Kings side like
this but otherwise White's lacking a
plan but the idea is to open the F file
so for instance if black just takes then
there's going to be a lot of pressure
against against f7 I don't think we can
and I think we can sacrifice right away
although maybe it's maybe even then yeah
maybe Bishop takes and and Knight takes
yeah I don't think it's really possible
to do it yet but yeah actually it is
well anyway you know so it's extremely
dangerous for black in any case black is
not gonna take on g3 so you played he
played g4 okay so here why it's idea
blacks getting passed pawn but at least
White has some squares for his pieces as
Bishop is open and
and so okay so he played 91 but this was
actually turned out to be a pretty big
choice tonight each four black would
play the same move f3 but it makes some
some differences we'll see what happens
in the game because it blocks flex h
spawn so on the other hand of course the
knight on h4 could be lacking prospects
and so in the future
f5 is going to be pretty easily for
black to cover this position is
definitely still better for black but
surprisingly well the white king is
relatively safe and white can try to
build up in the center of the board it's
just that objectively black is black it
stands very well here but he played 91
yeah so this is this by the way this is
a black burns note here this is what he
wrote okay thank you
okay so f3 of course again black does
not want the F file to open up plays f3
and here white played c3 so he
strengthened d4 strengthens d4 pawn and
he also let's sometimes the Queen will
come out in this kind of way
perhaps so black played Knight to d7
okay Knight a3 developing I don't know
if it's necessarily the best but it
doesn't seem worse than the alternatives
black should be better here blacks up
upon especially now black has this plan
as we'll see in a moment
okay so night a3 black play Knight b6
Bishop b3 of course keeping the bishop
Queen e7 Black's going to Castle
queenside most likely Knight to d3 so of
course can black take on e4 no right
between takes rook e1 so Knight to d3 so
the idea is well White's gonna just play
around this pawn here you have the f4
square we're going to occupy f4 or it
has these Center pawns these are these
are something okay so black played
Bishop d7 now who's gonna Castle
queenside Knight f4 what do you think
White's intending here
there's kind of an annoying move that
weights and tending most likely if he
gets the chance to who play it anyone
know yeah yeah Knight h5 could be a
little bit uncomfortable for black
because that Bishop when g7 this
important piece the night on h5 is going
to be hitting f6 also is this kind of so
it's it's making it it's creating some
lack of confusion lack of coordination
blacks position so anyone know what what
do you think black should play here any
ideas yeah
h5 Knight of 6 was also playable but you
have to watch out for the movie 5 maybe
he was worried about that but but h5 so
this is what black burns note again this
is what he wrote h4 is coming and it's
gonna be very hard for whites
you always know objectively the
evaluation of this position is
completely lost for a white at this
point I mean each force coming in white
really doesn't have any concrete threats
of his own but that's not all that's
gonna happen so this is a very fun game
it's not been too impressive so far but
we'll see what's gonna happen soon white
played Queen at e3 here so I think that
it was time to start considering him
move like h4 and then if black takes it
then Queen takes f3 and here white has
some some F file some pressure is he's
liberated his pieces still not very good
position for white actually but most
likely black wouldn't do that most
likely after h4 II would just Castle
queenside and it's also a bad position
for white at least his King is somewhat
safe though black will have to arrange
to attack g3 and h4 points may be
sacrificed on h4 maybe just try to
attacked you three in the long term it's
white has no real attack on the Queen
side so there's it's it should be
winning for black but it's a little bit
a little bit more complicated the white
played Queen to d3
black lady ch4 of course night to be
five so he's trying to create some kind
of threats now what would there's a lot
of good moves here for for black well
several good moves for black what would
anyone want to recommend what they would
play I don't know if anyone's gonna
guess the move that Blackburn would
Blackburn actually played any one ideas
anyone yeah yeah Castle queenside it's
the most natural move and it's far
better than what Blackburn actually
played but Blackburn's move was creative
and romantic attacking style and it was
also a off-hand game in a in a in a cafe
for one sovereign most likely whatever
that was worth the time I don't know oh
sorry yeah he actually you're right H
takes g3 first right exactly we should
first throw in this this is correct
should take on g3 yeah I mean castles
Queen se is also possible because it's
gonna be the same but yeah should throw
in this capture because why can't take
c7 now if white takes c7 King attacks
tonight so I have to take the rook and
now what is black play anyone know we're
gonna take with the pawn on h2 or take
the knight back or what else yeah
yeah Rock age - of course
so rook takes age - oops sorry Queen h4
is also good by the way but rook takes
age - and who sees the threat for black
there's a with the strongest threat the
most immediate enforcing threat yeah
well rook to Knight takes g2 so not
quite but yeah rook h1 and Queen h4
right so this is the biggest certain
there's no defense for white here rook
each one is a threat also Queen h4 is a
threat
so why can't after takes White has to
take back and now like like he said
castles Queen side was a very good move
so what if I takes the a pawn king b8
now that lose another tempo and now this
would be like the game except well we'll
see what the game was white has nothing
at all and his position is collapsing
we'll see that even this position were
blacks down at rook was the same kind of
thing it's also not so it's not so good
either for so okay so instead of that
though
Blackburn didn't want to defend c7 some
other way and he didn't want to allow
Knight to d5 eventual Knight to d5 so he
played c6 maybe he just wanted to
sacrifice the rook that's what he did
okay
even at the time they noted the game or
they they annotated the game in this in
some journal of the time called it a
daring move which probably was okay he
it's not a very good move actually they
even then they probably knew it wasn't
necessary at all okay so white took the
rook
and now black didn't even bother taking
the time to recapture an I take Sade was
actually maybe objectively speaking not
so bad for black now he's down the
exchange but still the white king is
very weak the a the H file is is is open
and the same kind of thing is happening
but Blackburn was not gonna back down he
continued his plan he developed the
night he wants to take you for and just
take his target is to take g3 pawn and
when that Pont is gone the Queen will
have access to h4 and so on so I took on
b6 okay now he's up a lot of material of
course what do you think black played
here did you take back on b6 no of
course not what do you think he did
continuing to throw his pieces in to
create this total melee 94 yeah 94 so
what's the material already down a rook
and a minor piece to right rook in a
minor piece but white King is the target
so we're not blacks not worrying about
material he's not counting pieces that's
that's for it's for other people not for
Blackburn so white here White's
took on d7 and you probably saw it I
didn't mean to show anyone see actually
okay so white took on d7 which is
obvious move but 96 would have refuted
blacks attack and it's not really such a
hard move to find Blackburn would not
have played this way if I was a
tournament game he was actually a really
good player but this he missed but 96
would have broken the line would have
now white removes the knight on e4 right
so black takes back and then Queen takes
e4 and it's just black just losses by
material so if like if he takes the
knight and Queen takes g4 White's up a
rope Bishop g5 is also coming to further
further simplify f3 pawn is there's
nothing for black he can resign here all
white had to find was 96 check but
remember this I mean even I
in the in a haze of with of cigar smoke
and vapors from whiskey even you might
miss 96 check ok so he he didn't find
that he'd put he took on d7 okay so
black took on g3 okay so so now blacks
got some serious threats rook each one
is one of the main ones so white really
has to do something it's a desperate
position
I mean rook h1 and rook each to is next
is also Queen h4 of course as a threat I
mean Rick h1 King f2 rock h2 and if he
takes the knight Queen h4 also rook h1
and taking the rook is kind of a so
there's anime and also Queen h4 there's
many threats so white really has to do
something immediately here so he'd
played 96 check only now unfortunately I
moved to too late now he said okay I
have to do something that's what
happened but let's see if if if he could
have defended himself here blackburn
recommended he should some okay here all
he said he said something must be done
but perhaps 92 would have been better
slightly better and so nigh to g2 let's
see what happens after Knight - g - okay
so the idea is if if takes then there's
no more attack early the pawn is then
white can take on f7 something like that
black and remember black is down so much
material white can give something back
so instead check King f2 and now the the
best looks like 93 there's some now the
king is wandering out we have three
moves we can take the knight we can go
keen e1 or we can go King u3 so we can
sacrifice the Queen Queen takes e4 but
then after Queen takes e4 black and just
to this and here
well white still has more than enough
material for the Queen right if three
minor pieces in a rook but two nights
are both under attack by threatening
Queen e2 followed by Queen 62 checkmate
and the pawns are really strong the
white king is exposed so this is losing
for whites
for instance I have to defend against
Queenie - so if 93 though don't even
have to take the night on d7 it's not
running away
so g3 and the May night while black
threatens to come in with Queen d3 and
in Queenie - or Queen h4 also is is
those are the two main threats and these
two pawns are too much for white to
handle these guys are not playing and
the night on d7 is also lost so this is
a winning position for black so so much
for sacrificing the Queen what if if
King e1 there's a cool move here F takes
G - still Black is down a rook in a
minor piece but it's getting a new queen
in a moment so again that's that's over
right what if the King steps up let's
see if someone can what does black play
here anyone see it's a force made in 3 4
4 moves
sometimes whoo-whee how do we find a
force maid it's easy to start looking by
looking okay you have Knight c5 check so
in the real game you know you win the
Queen that's gonna be winning for black
obviously but we're trying to find the
force mate the most accurate way you
would start thinking about well
discoveries but yeah my most that's the
thing you want to do then I would look
for second discovery so there's
discovered check but then I would know I
want to include another piece in the
attack
so Bishop h6 very good night of for is
the only move right King can't go back
then where's black play yeah Bishop f4
yeah the discoveries of course there's a
lot of discoveries that win but we want
to force mate so we're gonna take King
has to take and now what
mmm-hmm Queen g5 yeah Queen g5 King has
to take f5 mate so that's a nice
variation right so luckily for gusta for
anointment he he didn't play Knight to
g2 or Blackburn when it might have
played that what if he tries running
with this king well then we have again
this check the King can't cross the
e-file and if he takes here
checkmate okay so we also we have rook
takes f3 was interesting to try to just
give back some material remember white
has a huge excess of material here if if
takes then I don't know King f2 or
something like that and King is running
away black start maybe maybe even there
blacks winning but this rook h1 King g2
Queen h4 this is crushing because Queen
h2 is coming next so that didn't quite
work
also if King F to Queenie one by the way
after okay CH one King f king of to
Queenie one check and then Queen g1 so
there's actually this move 95 this is
really crazy now what's going on here
well this is so now now the ideas of
Queen h4 if black enacts his plan then
Knight takes f7 and Knight takes a cheat
and there's no mate right the King runs
away and there's so much material to
give back that is so if pawn takes then
white takes back with check King has to
move now we can now we can remove some
pieces I removes these pawns and
remember still a lot of material if if
black does the check like before
now King f2 I don't know if this I mean
this is looks like blacks running out of
material here so if he takes if he if he
takes the rook though Queen takes and
again he doesn't have a lot of material
left to give checkmate blacks just lucky
that he has a draw check King G to Queen
h4 threatening Queen age to mate Queen
takes g3 can anyone tell me what blacks
move is now rook g1 yeah and in this
position well it's two pieces in a rook
against the Queen but the white king is
open so deftly blacks not worse it's
most likely looks kind of drawers but I
guess maybe black is even less added on
AG to Bishop e5 I mean definitely black
and give perpetual at some point I
probably it's Josh but I don't know it's
anyway that that wasn't a win for black
at least clearly at least oh that's so
instead it Bishop takes e5 looks better
pawn takes a now Queen h4 White has only
one check King c8 and now White's up
rook and two minor pieces but the black
pieces are hovering around the White
King Queen age to mate as a threat looks
like it's just I don't see the defense
you know King F 294 at minimum or
actually King F to Knight f5 would be
would lead to mate because we cover III
so yeah that was looks like the best try
but it
oops it looks like so now instead white
did this and played Queen g6 so here
he's got the counter threat of Bishop to
g5 and he's ready to try to remove the
pawn on g4 anyone see blacks next move
here
this is this is the point where came the
player hood white was he was
anticipating a win but yeah 92 then King
f2 I don't want to make if I yeah if I
make the move it's gonna show you the
correct answer I think huh this a yeah
but king of two and King goes away to e3
in each for King III Bishop h6 King d3
King is running away and says black king
is not I mean to so much material so I'm
the black king is not they're very safe
that's a good try but mmm-hmm gage -
yeah
very good rook each - oops sorry rook H
- this was so that they have the
description here according to Blackburn
he said he he confessed that he has he
didn't see this when he played c6 which
was of course not at all forced from the
point he played c6 but but nothing
nothing bench or nothing win so and you
can read the rest he well he can read it
on the screen
huh anyway yeah he paranoia man gave a
slight start when he played this move
turned around looked at McDowell
McDonald who will see assuming we have
to get we'll have time for the next game
also one of the best players in the
world at the time who shrug and then he
shrugged his shoulders smiled but it was
a sickly kind of smile so the thread is
mate rook g2 right that's a response to
Bishop g5 for instance or any any move
you know King takes h2 is met by Queen
h4 King G 192 mate
so meanwhile yeah if so rook takes f3
was his only try and there's there's
nothing else white can what you can do
also rook f2 rock h1 mate so rip takes
f3 was the only only move to try pawn
takes again threatening rook to you too
and if Queen takes g3 then also roof g2
wins the Queen and this position is just
lost four white he'll lose the night on
d7 and white will have a rook and Bishop
against the Queen and a pawn but also
his king is wide open so it's good it's
no point in playing this so he played
King takes h2 allowing a much more
entertaining finish Queen h4 check King
g1 queen h1 king of two queen g2 has to
go to u3 because if King e1 Queen e2 is
made now Knight f1 discovering an attack
on the White Queen King at four Queen
six three six and now the game finished
up a black's attack continues and of
course this so now he only has a rook
for the Queen and then resigned at this
point so this was this was a
entertaining game not exactly correct
really the 96 checked that missed that
that both players missed really the only
huge turn of fate you know change of
fate in this game but oh okay
let's let's see now the next one
McDonnell against la Bourdonnais
London 1834 so this was these are the
two best players of the day this was of
course somewhat earlier than the
Blackburn game was he I forgot 1870 or
so this was this one or two players that
were before the time of Morphy around
the same time as Staunton I think I'm
not sure maybe a little bit after
Staunton and so this was the heart of
the Romantic period of chess and these
two players played I don't know how many
games are
huge number of games they played almost
unending match this was their fourth
match in London an ending series of
matches let's say this was I guess their
fourth match their fourth match the 16th
game but anyway this
okay so McDonald was white la Barthe la
Bourdonnais was black knight c6 d for CT
Knight 6405 who knows what the name of
this opening is now anyone know
Kalashnikov yeah this is actually well
you can find a lot of games and special
akov related opening with Knight f6 and
Knight c3 included the player that
secession akov is named after you have
gained accession akov actually later
came to prefer this this version though
the really the big difference is that
after the main move Knight to d5 the
mood that's always played now d6 white
doesn't have to play Knight c3 has a
move c4 which is the main difference but
what is black gained by this by giving
white that extra option well the
difference is for black that after
Knight c3 a six-night a3 there's a
number of different options both in this
position and after b5 95 so in this
position you got Bishop e7 and Bishop e6
which are especially Bishop e7 is a is a
is a popular move it's pretty reasonable
here and there's also be 595 which is
before is the threat so and then instead
of Knight f6 which would transpose to
special akov there's Knight G to e7
and there's Knight C to e7 so that's
just some opening information doesn't
have anything to do with this this game
because well white took on c6 which is
not not a move you would see at the top
level nowadays really over any level
practically but I don't think the
players were completely I mean they
there were there other games played at
the time with Knight to b5 so of course
Knight takes c6 positionally is a little
bit incorrect because it strengthens
black's pawn structure but white wanted
more free piece play and probably
he knew that you know anyway the funny
thing is that this opening almost
completely disappeared after the early
20th century Lasker played it a few
times actually but it almost completely
disappeared for a long time until
sveshnikov Stein because basically in
the classical chess d5 square creating a
weakness on d5 was considered
questionable I mean black created this
weakness and what what for that well he
gained some time he gained solidity in
the center so but you know why it took
on c6 so if people were playing this way
everyone would play this opening like
took back Bishop c4 he wants free play
but black has this Center now and it's
going to eventually become useful so
Knight f6 and Bishop g5 again another
move that looks a little bit I don't
know a little bit weird Knight c3 looks
more natural but I guess it allows the
pin Bishop before anyway why do I win
Bishop g5 and here black played very
quiet move Bishop e7 just breaking the
pin preparing to castle it's looks it's
pretty reasonable but I think I would
consider the move h6 here because if
white takes on f6
black gets two bishops four and it's a
very good Bishop the dark sword bishop
is coming to c5 and if white doesn't
take then you have to contend with
things like g5 and Knight takes e4 some
something like this and if here there's
a check looks like check here and this
can't be good for a white bishop c3
Knight c3 Bishop g7 d5 also coming and
whites
White's position is just you know so age
six well okay he didn't play that he
would play Bishop e7 so white now like
Queen e2 which also looks a little
strange to me Knight c3 keeping control
over d5 keeping better control over d5
looks more more natural he might have
been afraid of no I mean 94 did we take
in Bishop g5 96 and knight of seven so
that doesn't even you know that's not a
thinking thing so I'm showing this
variation that his takes takes Bishop
takes 96 and knight of seven doesn't
work for black so I don't know why I
didn't play Knights if it would Queen e2
okay
black now played very aggressively
hitting in a center with d5 so he is
gaining control the center and was tempo
2 so that's very good why decided to
take on f6 rather than take on d5 which
looks more natural take on d5 maybe give
a check on b5 Black's gonna be somewhat
better but he took on B have 6 I'm not
saying this White's play is very good at
this point it's not black took back now
Bishop e3 so he he avoided taking on d5
but he gave up an important bishop in
the kind of position where it's gonna be
very useful for black so black Castle
White Castle and now now a very good
move for black well what would you play
this move looks kind of you know the
plays been a little bit silly up to this
point but this move looks like a strong
move a typical modern chess or just
later than this time yeah a5 yeah he
played a5 with a threat of Bishop a6 and
also a for the pawn is going to become a
nuisance and it's gonna help the bishop
to develop so the very strong move
so here White has to deal with these two
threads and he doesn't really want to
play 84 Bishop basic c4 because that's
going to lead to real really ugly
position and problems on the B file and
so on so what should white play here
anyone got an idea
yeah yeah
what's that c4 yeah perhaps but c4 I'm
I'm a little concerned about a for your
ship moves and yeah maybe it's possible
because it takes on c4 Knight c3 within
a three I because he can't take right
bishop a six so Knight c3 a three and it
looks like White's positions collapsing
but it's a good try I don't know what
else we do here looks losing for a white
yeah so c4 yeah it's a try but it
doesn't look like it really works so
what he did is he took on d5 because he
wanted he needed to sit move his rook to
d1 and so he took on d5 so he'll be able
to go rooks he wanted to meet a4 with
Bishop takes d5 but actually she doesn't
want to take on d5 that's probably why
he took on f6 earlier is to avoid doing
it you should try that he's actually
played this and then after a four what
could White play to save the bishop
or Bishop c4 yeah so actually he had
this with some pressure on black centre
but black is better here he can play
Bishop e6 actually I could take and
Bishop takes in Knight c3 yeah I mean
this is
yeah this is this is a maybe you have to
go bish would be seven and then if yeah
yeah I mean maybe black has to go d4 I
don't know but this is this would leave
white in the game here so here probably
not a four is actually what black should
yeah anyway he went he went immediately
he took on d5 and then rook t1 now d4
this is a different if we imagine this
position where black saws the pawn on c6
and and white is upon on e4 that's a
different matter but here here black can
do this obviously doesn't want to allow
I guess takes in Knight c3 and this is
no this is this is not good for black so
he played d4 but black is now as his
center pawns are very strong in here's a
clearly better position so white here
played c4 and I think this makes things
a little bit worse c3 it's still so good
for black but at least a little bit more
pressure on the center c4 now black has
a passed pawn and okay so with Queen b6
strong move also I'm getting off the D
file and creating some threats on the B
file so white notice that black wasn't
actually threatening a four so he played
Bishop C to this problem though is he
wants to develop his night and if 92
then actually black could take the pawn
on b2 but did this first and so of
course you see what happens if Queen
takes b2 right what does white play now
someone else we haven't heard
yeah Bishop takes h7 right so he's not
going to fall for that
we've played Bishop d7 so okay night to
d2 and now now takes on b2 also is not
so good because white could white could
check on h7 and rook b1 regain the
regained the the piece and still it's
not best so black just played rook to e8
he wants to play e4 his main goal here
is to break this sort of semi blockade
he wants to push his pawns forward in
the center this is so were these two
strong center pawns one of them passed
supported by two bishops so white played
94 okay so black should preserve his
bishop so he played Bishop d8 white
played c5 it's doing everything he can
to get some sort of counter play Queen
c6 threatening f5 is checkmate on g2
that's why he played f3 and now black
played Bishop e7 so he wants to stop
Knight to d6 of course which is now a
threat Knight to d6 will be annoying
I never thread yeah and he also
pressures the c5 pawn
I played rook c1i I was thinking
probably Bishop c7 looks more natural to
me but it's his move was also also good
see seven rooks c1 f5 now this is I I
mean this move maybe maybe black could
could start with King h8 but this move
is really leads to some very fascinating
play Black has his long-term advantages
as Center pawns as bishop but now
White's going to win some material I'm
assuming that de la Bourdonnais saw
White's next couple of moves and and
realized that he was going to get a very
strong attack anyway why did whatever he
could he'd checked on c4 if he just
moves his night away black takes c5 most
likely and have very strong he'll be his
center pawns will just crush try to
eventually as he played Queen c4 check
King h8 Bishop a4 so Queen is under
attack
Queen age 6 so now white is to take the
rook otherwise again blacks position is
just or his position is going to be
overwhelming without white getting some
material for it
so if knighted he's sorry he he played
Knight to g6 if Bishop takes the a then
pawn takes and this is crushing for
black so for instance actually this is
just a second remember what happened
this is what happens if Knight to d6
black takes it and after Bishop takes
the 8th in Bishop c7 and the idea is 'if
or coming up next
the Bishop's hanging on e8 and ye4 is
also threat so this isn't this is also
not good for a white so he he instead he
took immediately black took here and now
cc6 if if Bishop d7 then black checks
here
and he takes enough three with the
winning attack taking on f2 is coming
next the bishop on b7 is also taking
part in the attack and if y blocks it
out then it's going to be checkmate in a
couple moves wreck F 2 followed by Queen
f3 or or discovery was the rook if King
g1 rookie - and then checkmate in a
couple moves so that's so sorry took
took so he played c6 shutting out the
bishop at least so black took here and
now white white had to defend against
the threat so what do you think happens
if white takes on b7 anyone see this is
the same pattern so if that wouldn't be
too hard
yeah Queen III yeah you three king h1
takes and then once again rook rook F -
yeah and checkmate either Queen f3 or
for instance here we got this move and
then Queen f3 and Queens you - so so
White had to defend against Queen e3
defend against the teh the captain he
needed to defend the second ring so he
played rook c2 so here check and now
rook F 2 is by far the best chance here
and black would so for instance the idea
is if black takes on g2 then Queen e2
and white defends this is not good for
black wax down the exchange and his
attack is drying up so for instance
White's threatening to trade Queens and
take on f8 and so that that's not good
here black could play Bishop c8 I think
there's even some even even some some
idea like like this and
Oh d3 is
you three is coming next if Queen to
three then
and this
this is yeah now he too next this is so
Bishop a6 that was actually that's
actually very anyway this this was a at
least much better defense rook F to but
white played King h1 okay so now what do
you think black plays here
if we take G to that rook takes back and
White's King is pretty safe
we need these pawns actually turns out
yeah yeah
f2 yeah I'm sorry he played this first I
think he could go have two but he played
this first now Bishop on e8 is hanging
there should be seven but now F - okay
so anyone see the thread like what if
white takes here what does black play
now yeah
mmm Queenie one Queen f1 yep Queen D 1
and half 1 and black wins so so f2 so
white had to defend against that so he
played rook f1
there's Queen Queen f1 was met by oh do
you see what happens after Queen f1 who
sees the good move for black here yeah
Bishop e6 very good Bishop a6 queen is
hanging has nowhere to go
blocking doesn't do any good and if
Queen takes then again Queen e1 if white
takes pawn takes and then made and if
Queen f1 once again this move so and
then Queen takes and then f1 so nice
variation
ok so white played rook F 1 so now d3 so
black is down the exchange here but his
pawns are marching forward d3 white
played rook c3 hoping to attack the
point maybe technically better to go
here but we'll see that after simply
capture and then e4 it's gonna be sort
of like the game but tempo doesn't even
matter for 4 wasn't wasn't wouldn't be
enough to save white so instead white
played rook c3 black took so now white
White's took back creating his own past
pond on the seventh rank but it's not
going anywhere if rook takes c3 then
Queen e2 would be a good answer
threatening the rook on f1 and black is
winning so white took E for protecting
the pawn and so now we've got this
really unique position whites whites
down the whites up the exchange has this
his own pawn but these three pawns are
going to defeat all of White's pieces
Queen c8 wait does everything you can
because what else is he going to do here
Black's doing the same moves no matter
what which we're going to see in a
moment Queen c8 black blocked with the
bishop so he's keeping his rook on FAL
rook to da was also possible I think but
this was good
now I played Queen C for he couldn't
find any anything anything here so for
instance Queen takes and then rook c8
doesn't work because black can just
defend with Queen g5 or Queen b6 so so
white went back with the Queen to c4
also if he played queen c5 black could
trade Queens and then D 3 and there's no
stopping the pawns so white when Queen
c4 we knew why rook c1 so Queen takes F
1 is the thread and rooks Queen can't be
captured either soruq C 1 D 2 and white
White's now pretty desperate because
rook is under attack
well white played Queen c5 so the best
try threatening the rook on f8 and if
King g8 white can give a check then
black plays worksheet it doesn't even
need us raqami F file anymore both rook
and Bishop are just playing defense but
Queen and pawns are gonna win everything
so white wind rook to d1 now the rooks
are blockading all they can they protect
each other there's no Queen takes D 1 B
because there's no Rokon f8 anymore we
don't have that anymore
but it's still not enough what do you
think black plays now anyone anyone know
yeah ok yeah III so yeah you three and
now these pawns are are going to just
break through Queen C 3 white tried so
now what let's be careful what is what
do we play now yeah
yeah
yeah good so ye if e to immediately then
whites now attacking whites now
attacking the Queen three times all by a
different x-rays but takes and and now
what do we play here huh Queen takes
yeah nah trick takes with Queen takes
even this is winning for black dough its
up a piece right yeah so but yeah Queen
takes f1 or Queen takes d1 as he played
in the game rook takes D 1 e2 is much
more aesthetic way to finish the game
three pieces on the seventh right three
pawns on the seventh rank you don't see
that very often
of course with Queen takes D to black
plays f1 Queen so that was that was the
end of this this is a famous final
position I think that the game has some
instructional value see how black built
up his play though none of these games
can be expected to be perfect it was a
whole different atmosphere and people
were trying to forge their own paths
which now would nowadays when we play we
have so much experience from other
people's experience that we can call
upon and back then they didn't have it
and there were only really just a few
chess books and there were that were
that existed and so it was it was a
different different different world for
chess than nowadays we spend time
preparing deep into the game on a
computer so anyone have any questions at
all
No okay so yep okay thank you
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]